en el último vídeo aprendimos como la
miosina la miosina 2 en particular que
es cuando hay dos de estas cabezas de
miosina y sus colas se entrelazan entre
sí como la miosina 2 puede usar atp para
esencialmente tirar de un filamento de
actina o caminar sobre un filamento de
actina inician unidas luego el atp viene
y se une a la miosina y éstas se separan
de la actina luego el atp se hidroliza
en atp y un grupo fosfato cuando esto
sucede esa energía se libera pone a la
miosina en un estado de alta energía que
de cierto modo carga la proteína como un
resorte y luego se une a otra muesca en
el filamento de la actina y después del
grupo fosfato se va y en ese momento es
cuando el cambio de conformación en esta
proteína es suficiente para generar un
golpe de poder para empujar el filamento
de actina y se pueden imaginar ya sea
que mueve la miosina a lo que sea que
esté conectada a la miosina a la
izquierda o lo que sea que esté
conectada a la actina a la derecha vamos
a hablar mucho más sobre a que están
conectados en futuros vídeos
ahora quizá tengan algunas preguntas
rondando en la cabeza la miosina se
esforzó mucho para tirar de esta cosa
hay cierta atención tirando en la otra
dirección dijimos que esto es lo que
sucede en los músculos por lo que debe
haber algo de peso u otra resistencia
entonces qué sucede cuando ésta se
libera en el primer paso cuando el atp
se le unió y se liberó el filamento de
actina no regresaría a donde estaba
antes especialmente si hay algo de
tensión que lleva hacia esa dirección y
la respuesta es simple eso es que esta
no es la única proteína de messina que
actúa sobre está activa hay otras a lo
largo de la cadena quizá haya una aquí
mismo quizá haya una acá todas están
trabajando a su propio ritmo en
diferentes momentos así que hay tantas
de estas que cuando una está desactivada
otra podría estar en su golpe de poder u
otra podría estar activada así que si de
repente una se libera el filamento de
actina no retrocederá a donde estaba
ahora la siguiente pregunta que podrían
estar pensando es como encendemos y
apagamos esta situación tenemos control
sobre nuestro
que puede activar o desactivar este
sistema de medicina que esencialmente
camina sobre la actina y para entender
esto hay otras dos proteínas que entran
en juego estas son la tropo miosina y
troponina voy a escribirlo tropo miosina
y troponina en color diferente voy a
volver a dibujar la actina haré un
dibujo muy tosco del filamento de actina
digamos que ese es un filamento de
actina con sus pequeños surcos en una
estructura helicoidal más o menos así y
en realidad estos surcos son una
estructura helicoidal pero no nos
preocupemos mucho por eso en lo que
dibujamos hasta ahora al menos en el
último vídeo teníamos estas pequeñas muy
finas podemos verlas como pies o cabezas
o lo que sea que se adhiera y luego
según donde se encuentren en el ciclo de
atp pueden ponerse en marcha o ser
cargadas como resorte e ir al siguiente
y retroceder ahora además de esta activa
en realidad tenemos esta proteína troppo
miosina y la proteína troppo miosina se
enrolla alrededor de la actina
es nuestra activa esta es una de las dos
cabezas de la miosina 2 y luego tenemos
nuestra propio miosina
la tropo miosina se enrolla alrededor
este es un dibujo muy tosco pero pueden
imaginar que está enrollada por atrás y
luego sigue así y luego pasa por atrás y
luego sigue así está enrollada y unida a
la actina por otra proteína llamada
troponina digamos que está unida allí y
esto no es exacto pero digamos que está
unida allí y allí y allí y allí y allí
por la troponina voy a etiquetarlo
troponina y esto es tropo miosina para
que puedan imaginarlo la troponina es
como los clavos en la actina y dicta
dónde está la tropo miosina entonces
cuando un músculo no está contraído
resulta que la tropo miosina está
bloqueando la miosina y he leído un
montón de reportes sobre esto y creo que
todavía es un área de investigación no
está 100% claro cómo funciona la tropa
miosina puede estar bloqueando la
miosina para que no pueda pegarse
la actina donde normalmente se une por
lo que no podrá arrastrarse sobre ella o
puede ser que si la miosina está unida a
la actina evita que se libere y se
deslice sobre la actina para evitar que
camine o pueden ser ambas en resumidas
cuentas esta tropo miosina bloquea la
cabeza de la miosina esta es la cabeza
de miosina para que no se arrastre sobre
la actina ya sea bloqueando físicamente
su sitio de enlace o si ya está unida
evitando que pueda seguir deslizándose
sobre la actina de cualquier manera la
está bloqueando y la única forma de
desbloquear la es que las troponinas
realmente cambien su conformación que
cambien su forma y la única manera de
que cambien su forma es si hay una alta
concentración de iones de calcio
entonces si hay un montón de iones de
calcio si hay una concentración lo
suficientemente alta estos iones de
calcio se unirán con la troponina y eso
cambiará la conformación de la troponina
lo suficiente como para mover la
configuración de la tropa miosina así
que permítanme escribir
normalmente la tropo miosina está
bloqueando pero luego cuando hay una
alta concentración de iones de calcio se
unen con la troponina y cambian la
conformación de la troponina para que la
tropo miosina se quite de ahí entonces
hay una alta concentración de calcio sea
una la troponina quita la tropo miosina
y de repente sucede lo que hablamos en
el último vídeo estas cosas pueden
comenzar a caminar sobre la actina oa
empujar la actina hacia la derecha como
quieran verlo pero luego si la
concentración de calcio baja disminuye
la concentración de calcio los calcio se
desprenden de la troponina necesitamos
tener suficiente siempre por aquí porque
si la concentración se vuelve realmente
baja aquí estas cosas comenzarán a irse
entonces la troponina regresa a la
conformación estándar lo que hace que la
topo miosina bloquee a la miosina
nuevamente así que en realidad nada de
esto es sencillo esto se descubrió hace
unos 50 o 60 años y se pueden imaginar
que observar estas cosas o crear
experimentos para saber definitivamente
lo que está sucede
no es para nada sencillo pero la idea es
sencilla sin calcio la tropo miosina
está bloqueando la capacidad de la
miosina para unirse donde necesita
unirse o deslizarse sobre la actina para
que pueda seguir empujándola pero si la
concentración de calcio es lo
suficientemente alta se unirá a la
troponina que esencialmente clava a la
tropa miosina que está enrollada
alrededor de la actina y cuando cambian
su conformación con los iones de calcio
quita la tropa miosina del camino para
que la miosina pueda hacer lo que hace
así que se pueden imaginar que estamos
construyendo una manera para que los
músculos se contraigan pero aún mejor
para que podamos controlar la
contracción muscular entonces si tenemos
una alta concentración de calcio dentro
de la célula el músculo se contraerá y
si tenemos una baja concentración de
calcio nuevamente de repente éstas se
liberarán serán bloqueadas y el músculo
se relajara nuevamente